[Music]
well the new school year is upon us and
i think we're are we going to talk about
that are we going to go over to rocky
now what's going on
rocky is there come on we got to talk
about vintage clothes
some shopping here some tags with rocky
she
we are we are doing some shopping today
tell us what's going on out there
hey mercedes njc we are at glam factory
vintage over in the arts district in las
vegas obviously and it
is the coolest shop lance don't fall
there's a lot in here obviously our
cameraman is tripping over everything
because it's packed with all of these
vintage treasures this is stephanie the
owner of this beautiful place stephanie
thank you for having us first and
foremost this is a piece of history in
vegas
it is thank you so much for coming i
appreciate it of course so tell us a
little bit about your shop
well we've been here going on eight
years right here on the
end of the arts district on third in
colorado
and it's a little 1920s building and
this is my second home
wow it really is this is beautiful it
feels like home too so whatever you want
you can find here you sure can
so tell us about the items in this
beautiful place and
you know let's talk about some things
because i feel like everything has a
story
right in a vintage shop oh absolutely
some of my favorite things are costume
jewelry and our cat
[Laughter]
our costume jewelry a lot of these
pieces belonged to
ladies that were show girls in the 50s
and 60s awesome
and they're available now and it's so
amazing to watch girls use them and
accessorize
yes maybe for proms quinceaneras
holidays
dates and just to see really you know it
comes out and be worn again
beautiful and let's talk about this
peach suit because personally
i mean i love this but i think jc would
i think jc could rock this a little bit
better thanks right it's so
good ombre bill bottoms all these cool
pockets
this is a really neat piece it came from
a jonathan's men's shop here in las
vegas
anna they closed i want to say 1979
and uh in march this year beginning part
of march i was able to buy
all of their old inventory oh my gosh so
you you just keep stocking and stocking
in your shop from
from venture shops all around town i buy
whole all through the streets i buy
estates um i sell trade wherever i can
get it however i can get it i do
so what are some of the period pieces or
what are some of the years that you
specialize in
um you know we're really killer for
1970s we have a lot of good 60s looks
weird and we've got a lot of authentic
40s
50s pinup looks like a thing speaking of
pinup
i hear that katy perry wanted this guy
right here she did
she did a few years ago during one of
the awards that was
uh award shows that was here in town she
came in with her dancers
and they were shopping and having a
great time and she was asking me
you know would i be willing to part with
it and i just couldn't it's a special
piece that lives here
not even for katy perry you guys so
obviously this place is very exclusive
so come on down to glam factory vintage
here in the arts district
coming up later in the show though i'm
gonna go treasure hunting and figure out
a
nice thrifted outfit for myself so stay
tuned for that oh